[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous venons signé la
convention du guichet unique paris
saclay qui est un outil un petit peu
innovant dans le monde de la résidence
universitaire puisqu'il s'agit de faire
en sorte que sur un site donné qui est
le site paris saclay des étudiants n'est
qu'un seul point d'accès pour faire
toutes leurs demandes de logement quel
que soit l'établissement dans lequel ils
sont censés étudié l'année prochaine
donc à travers ce site c'est la
rencontre à la fois des opérateurs c'est
à dire les gestionnaires et ceux qui ont
construit les résidences la rencontre
des établissements qui sont à qui
accueillent ces étudiants sur le site et
des étudiants afin qu'ils formulent des
demandes en fonction d'établissements
dans lesquels il souhaite être inscrits
l'année prochaine
très concrètement le principe est le
suivant un étudiant qui par exemple
vient de sortir de prépa y vient de
réussir ces concours et qui
potentiellement peut être inscrit sur
une école du plateau va se connecter sur
ce guichet unique et faire sa demande en
disant je veux tel résidence et
j'appartiens tel établissement
l'établissement va recevoir cette
demande et dire effectivement cet
étudiant est inscrit chez nous fait
partie de notre public prioritaire c'est
à dire qu'on souhaite absolument qu'ils
soient logés sur le plateau est pas
renvoyer cette information au guichet
qui va dire dans ces cas-là il ya
adéquation entre la demande des
étudiants le souhait d'établissement de
l'accueillir et la possibilité d'avoir
un logement dans une résidence adaptée
et donc la conjonction de ces trois
facteurs à faire que l'étudiant va
recevoir instantanément une proposition
de logement là où il a souhaité
pour les logements sont de différentes
typologies donc vous avez le classique
t1 c'est à dire le studio individuel
complètement équipé bien entendu vous
avez des solutions de colocation à
plusieurs en général trois ou quatre
personnes dans des logements qui sont du
coup un petit peu plus grands aideront
lesquels on partage soit à la fois la
cuisine une ou deux salles de bain en
fonction du nombre d'étudiants qui adore
dans le temps le secteur et puis bien
entendu tous les autres espaces communs
puisqu'il faut savoir que les résidents
y compris sur le plateau de saclay
propose un panel large de services que
ce soit la halle a pris les salles de
musique les salles de sport et bien
entendu toutes les installations qui
sont construits sur le plateau qu'elles
soient culturelles ou sportives sont
elles aussi mutualisés part étant
étudiant qui sont logés ici de
bénéficier de toutes ces services qui
qu'on le trouve sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et bien entendu un certain nombre de
solutions de restauration seront
proposées que ce soit les restaurants
universitaires classiques du crous qui
ont beaucoup évolué depuis ce qu'on a
connu dans les années 50
et puis aussi incertain de solutions de
proximité à la fois en termes de
cafétéria et une distribution
automatique le service d'ailleurs le
guichet unique l'outil informatique sera
disponible dès la mi juin de façon à
permettre à ceux qui sortent de sorte de
concours ou selon bientôt arriver sur le
sur le secteur de faire leurs demandes
dans les dix jours qui viennent
[Musique]